I WILL BE IN TROUBLE.
ALL RIGHT, GOOD TO SEE YOU
SENATOR.
JOINING US NOW, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KARL ROVE.
I WANT TO LOOK AT THE MAGNITUDE
OF THIS THROUGH A POLITICAL
PRISM.
WE ARE GOING TO WATCH THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE WE GOT A PREVIEW,
SPEAKING OF SOUTH CAROLINA, THIS
WEEKEND, OF HOW RADICAL, HOW
EXTREME THIS A DEMOCRATIC -- A
NEW DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY
HAS BECOME.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY ARE
ALL CREATING A CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD.
THEY ARE ALL TRYING TO OUT-
OUT--OUT SOCIALIST THE NEXT ONE
AND DESTROY THEIR OPPONENTS.
BUT YOU ADD TO THIS, THIS ALL
HAPPENED ON BIDEN-OBAMA'S WATCH.
YOU ADD TO THIS DEVIN NUNES
WARNED ABOUT THIS IN 2014, THE
RUSSIANS WOULD DO THIS.
THEY LET IT HAPPEN.
IF THEY DID NOTHING TO PREVENT
IT.
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT EXACTLY
RIGHT, BECAUSE WE HAVE
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYING THAT HE
WAS GOING TO SPEAK SHARPLY TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
I'M SURE PUTIN LEFT THAT MEETING
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA SHAKING IN
HIS BOOTS AND ASKING HIMSELF WHY
HE EVER EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT
TRYING TO INTERFERE IN THE U.S.
ELECTIONS?
I'M OBVIOUSLY BEING A LITTLE
SARCASTIC.
PRESIDENT OBAMA NOW SAYS -- AND
HIS DEFENDERS -- NOW SAY THE
REASON HE DID NOT ISSUE A MORE
PUBLIC DENUNCIATION OF THE
RUSSIAN EFFORTS WAS HE DIDN'T
WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION TO IT.
BUT LOOK, YOU ARE RIGHT, THIS
HAPPENED ON THEIR WATCH.
EVERY INDICATION IS THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO TAKE A
FIRM STEPS TO TAKE      PREVENTA
FIRM STEPS TO TAKE      PREVENTY
FOREIGN ACTORS FROM
INTERFERING IN THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, AND I'M
SURE EVERY AMERICAN THINKS THAT
IS WISE.
>> Sean: KARL, YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND POLITICS A ROUND OR TWO,
MAYBE LONGER.
LIKE ME YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS,
SO EXCITED TO HAVE MUELLER, AND
I KNOW JIM JORDAN, MARK MEADOWS,
I'VE READ THEIR CLOSED-DOOR
QUESTIONING OF MANY PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS, FAIRLY -- TO
BE HONEST -- BRUTAL, AND THEY
HAVE EXPOSED A LOT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT, HOW DOES HE
JUSTIFY HIRING HILLARY'S
ATTORNEY?
ONLY DEMOCRATS?
HOW DOES HE ANSWER THE QUESTION
ABOUT THE NINE AND A HALF MINUTE
PRESS CONFERENCE THAT HE SCREWED
UP BADLY?
HOW DOES HE MENTION THE QUESTION
THEY HAVE TIME FOR TAXI
MEDALLIONS, LOAN APPLICATIONS,
AND TAXES?
A BROAD MANDATE THAT DIDN'T
INCLUDE A DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
PAID FOR BY THE OTHER CANDIDATE?
>> WELL, AND THAT IS ONE WAY TO
LOOK AT IT.
I LOOK AT IT FROM A DIFFERENT WY
I LOOK AT IT FROM A DIFFERENT W?
SINCE THE MUELLER REPORT CAME
OUT, TWO THINGS HAVE HAPPENED:
THE PRESIDENT'S FAVORABLES AND
UNFAVORABLE TO HAVE STABILIZED,
AND THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO
SAY THEY DON'T WANT TO GO
THROUGH IMPEACHMENT I DON'T
THINK IMPEACHMENT IS JUSTIFIED
HAS RISEN DRAMATICALLY.
SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH THE
MUELLER REPORT DOES THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HEARD ALL ABOUT IT, MANY
WENT OUT AND BOUGHT COPIES OF
IT, MANY HEARD ABOUT IT ON CABLE
TV AND ON THE INTERNET, FOR
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF TIME, AND
WHAT THEY DID IS THEY DECIDED,
ESSENTIALLY -- UNLESS YOU ARE A
HARDCORE DEMOCRAT, UNLESS YOU
HAVE ALREADY CONDEMNED
DONALD TRUMP NOT ONLY TO
IMPEACHMENT, BUT TO PRISON, IF
YOU ARE A AND ORDINARY AMERICAN
WHO DOESN'T HAVE THE STRONG
PARTISAN OPINIONS, THE MUELLER
REPORT LEAD YOU TO SAY "IT'S
OVER!"
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
THE LONGER THEY TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, THE MORE THEY
APPEAR TO BE BENT UPON
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT AND
THAT ALONE, THE MORE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
CONCLUDE, HEY, THOSE PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE OUR BEST INTERESTS AT
HEART.
AND THINK ABOUT THIS PAIR THE
NUMBER ONE MESSAGE OF THE
DEMOCRATS TODAY IS INVESTIGATE
AND IMPEACH.
NUMBER TWO MESSAGE, GROWING UP,
GETTING CLOSE TO IT, IS
BERNIE SANDERS,
ELIZABETH WARREN, DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE MESSAGE
OF "FREE EVERYTHING."
FREE COLLEGE, WE'RE GOING TO
FORGIVE YOUR DEBTS, GUARANTEE
BASIC INCOME, THOUSAND DOLLAR
CHECK EVERY MONTH FOR EVERY
AMERICAN, MEDICARE FOR ALL,
ABOLISH OR PRIVATE INSURANCE,
HAVE A GOVERNMENT TAKE IT
OVER -- I MEAN, FREE EVERYTHING!
GUARANTEED FEDERAL JOB FROM ALL
OF THESE LUNATIC PROPOSALS THAT
WE HEAR FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
THAT IS THE SECOND MESSAGE.
WHERE IS THE WINNING MESSAGE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS IN EITHER ONE OF
THOSE TWO THINGS?
MUELLER'S APPEARANCE BEFORE THE
SENATE, BEFORE THE HOUSE, EXCUSE
ME.
I'M SURE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO ASK HIM TOUGH QUESTIONS, AND
THEY DESERVE ANSWERS.
THE GENERAL IMPRESSION IS GOING
TO BE, THIS IS OVER.
WHY DO WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT?
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, HE SAID
ALL HE IS GOING TO DO IS REPEAT
THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.